Speaker 1: But as I mentioned, if you want
to lay the blame for the failures in Afghanistan
at anybody's feet, it has to be at the feet
of George W. Bush.
And right now, both Biden and twice impeached
former President Donald Trump seem to want
to lay the blame at each other's feet.
You've got members of the Biden administration
coming out and saying no to everything that's
happening right now is Donald Trump's fault.
And then Trump, of course, is issuing his
idiotic statement saying, look at all these
failures of Biden, I left him a road map and
he didn't follow it.
This is his fault.
These two going back and forth and back and
forth, completely ignoring.
This all started under George W. Bush, folks,
and I know I've said this plenty of times
have already said it today.
It's going through four administrations at
this point.
But.
George W. Bush's name was not mentioned once
on the Sunday talk shows this past week and
now once.
You cannot talk about Afghanistan without
talking about George W. Bush and the failures
of the war on terror, the failures of this
nation building that we went on over there.
That's where all the failures began and yes,
it is accurate to say that both Democrat and
Republican administrations came along after
that and continued this disastrous policy.
But they weren't the ones who implemented
it, everyone who has inherited this Afghanistan
mess since George W. Bush left office hasn't
had a roadmap.
They haven't known what the heck to do over
there.
So we keep bombing, we keep sending weapons.
We keep the killing going, we keep the troops
over there, maybe we're going to bring a home
that maybe we're not, you know, that happened
during Obama and then instead.
Oh, no, we're going to send more.
Happened under we're going to bring him home.
No way we got it, we got we got to send a
few more.
We're going to put more military contractors
over there were going to bring troops back,
some of them.
But we're going to double down on the number
of military contractors we have over there.
That also happen, by the way, earlier this
year with the Biden administration, because
nobody has known.
What to do?
Because there was never any real goal.
The so-called war on terror was such a vague
concept that it could mean anything, and we
went into it obviously with a lot of hostility
following 9/11, we were not thinking clearly
as a nation.
We wanted revenge.
We wanted retribution.
And, of course, because George W. Bush had
all these, you know, former officials from
the first Gulf War in his administration,
they wanted to go back over there and finish
the job.
So they focused on Iraq, they kept Afghanistan
over there on the back burner.
We had to do Taliban.
Yeah, we're going to get them.
But Iraq was the big prize.
So Afghanistan fell by the wayside.
We still kept troops there.
We still kept fighting there.
But never really had a plan there that was
kind of just the for show part, oh, we're
looking for bin Laden over in Afghanistan,
that's that's what we're doing over there.
But, hey, we just got Saddam Hussein.
Right.
And that's that's what everybody wanted.
Following 9/11, as Corey Robin pointed out
on Twitter the other day.
Ninety percent of the American public supported
sending troops to Afghanistan.
So when I say we weren't thinking clearly
as a nation, that's the kind of thing I'm
talking about here, 90 percent of people supported
this thing, not knowing what it was really
about, not knowing what was going on.
But George Bush and his administration lied
us over there and got us stuck.
And then they left and Obama continued, then
he left and Trump continued.
Now we've got Biden pulling troops out, Trump
saying, Oh, look at what an idiot you are.
Again, ignoring the fact that just a few months
ago, he was begging Biden to finish what he
started pulling all the troops out.
At this point, it wouldn't have mattered if
we had pulled troops out of there in 24 or
20, 10 or 20, 20 or even 20, 30, this would
have happened.
This same thing that we're watching unfold
right now with the Taliban capturing Kabul,
this still would have happened.
Because there was no goal, there was no strategy,
there was no actual peace deal negotiated
between the U.S. government and the Taliban
and the Afghani government, and this is what
we got.
This is the disaster that we have to deal
with now.
And again, I don't think anybody really knows
what to do about this.
Do we just let the Taliban take over, walk
away and say, well, good luck, you got a mess
on your hands?
I don't agree with sending troops back over
there, I think it's just another disaster,
you're just prolonging this from happening
again.
And nobody knows the answer, the answer, though,
is that we have to continue to help the people
of Afghanistan.
We need to be able to get them out of the
country, we need to take in as many refugees
as we possibly can here in the United States.
I don't want to hear anger from conservatives
about this.
We put them in this situation.
We've got to take care of them.
And that's the best thing we can do right
now.
I am Faran Cousins from Ring of Fire, more
of me, you can get it at Ring of Fire or excuse
me, YouTube dot com slash the ring of fire.
I'm sitting in for David Pakman today.
We'll be right back.